my mom always used to say it's in the
wrist it's in the wrist I like that
wrist if you ain't got the wrist it
ain't gonna come out exactly or what's
the other one put your foot in it don't
put your foot in yeah yeah put your foot
on I've heard for sure yeah I don't know
where that came from but when we say it
it's like she put her foot in there yeah
one two three
what's cooking my name is Chef Elisa
Reynolds executive chef and host of
searching for soul food I am here with
the beautiful amazing actress rutina
Wesley and we about to make some soul
food Regina tell the people what we
making and we are making my
grandmother's collard greens which are
my favorite I love that tell me what's
in them okay have white onion white
onion red pepper flakes red pepper
flakes a little salt and pepper chicken
bouillon we've got some garlic and onion
powder the green and the gorgeous green
some cabbage
yeah and a Louisiana hot link
you always got to finish it with a link
with a link yeah
yeah how do we start well I've never
made it
registered
wait no I know
um I know we gotta do granny right we're
going to do it right we're gonna do it
right so we're channeling granny and I
have a feeling we're going to start with
yes so let's why don't we season the
broth okay I think she would do that now
we'll start with our bouillon yeah we'll
pop that in there
and then what feels right is all the
seasonings in what does soul food mean
to you comfort it means home
it's kind of our love language mmm
grandma like gosh that smells delicious
but it smells really good yeah so we're
just gonna go ahead and
drop in our collard greens into this
beautiful broth we have here with the
sausage and the links
and we're gonna cook this down
are we putting our feet in there we put
our foot in here we're putting both legs
okay when I was in Appalachia during my
search
tail was huge that's how they made their
greens they they mix kale in them and so
that blew my mind because soul food now
becomes Regional
from what was available at that time in
the land but cooked similarly we have
similarities of techniques which
obviously came from indigenous or Africa
and
we were cooking them at the same time
but flipping them different ways and
didn't know it
until I started searching for soul food
until the Cabbage now and you know what
I wanted to ask you because like have
you been anywhere to where you're like
this isn't quote unquote our soul food
but it makes me it invokes these same
emotions and feelings um definitely when
I was in Italy I felt so like good and
like nurtured from the inside out from
the food right no no no
no no no no do it again I like that
I love it so let's get it going let's
see oh
I think we did I think we did it right
oh my gosh it smells so good I think we
we're gonna make her proud today
[Music]
gorgeous history in a bowl mm-hmm
Cheers Cheers
this is for the ancestors
mmm thanks for watching and make sure
you check out searching for soul food
now streaming on Hulu also Center your
favorite soul food recipes with hashtag
soul food Hulu
period period
such a good song
[Music]